health care systems are helping us to
live longer healthier lives but as we
live longer in the population ages our
current systems are becoming harder to
afford patients expect more and advance
new treatments and technologies are also
increasingly expensive government
spending on health care and long term
care has been increasing from about 5.7
percent of GDP in the EU in the 80s to
eight point seven percent of GDP in 2015
on current trends this figure could
reach 12.5 percent by 2060 the situation
varies considerably but governments in
the EU on average now spend about
fifteen percent of their budgets on
health care making it the second biggest
item after social protection but there
is plenty we can do to lower costs while
maintaining access to quality care and
improving public health investing more
in disease prevention and promoting good
health could reduce the burden of
preventable diseases investing in
primary care could help citizens stay
healthy and reduce the need for heavy
Hospital based treatments that have a
greater impact on quality of life the
cost of medication can be lowered by
promoting the rational use of medicines
and avoiding over prescription joint
procurement can cut costs significantly
without affecting quality or safety
several countries have agreed to adopt
this approach for medical products
linked to contagious diseases better
coordination between care providers can
empower patients with chronic conditions
to live independently and avoid
unnecessary hospitalization the European
Commission is helping Member States to
meet these challenges by providing
independent advice facilitating
cooperation and offering concrete
solutions these include the EU
health action plan to harness health
tools to improve health care for
patients giving them more control of
their care while bringing down costs and
facilitating cooperation between member
states on the assessments of new
technologies to ensure there are
efficient and cost effective finally the
EU also provides funding for medical
research and structural reforms thereby
proving expertise not only to save money
but making people's lives better the
European economy stronger together
[Music]